Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass nur Mist drin ist, deswegen habe ich jetzt auch nichts großartig
in den Titel geschrieben, sondern einfach, dass wir uns mal ne Runde jubeln lassen.
Also ich gehe auch stark davon aus, dass es nur Schrott drin ist.
Das einzige, wofür sich Prime Day immer lohnt, ist wenn man Amazon, also zumindest bisher,
ist wenn man Amazon eigene Geräte kaufen will, also wenn ihr irgendein Fire HD Tablet
oder sowas kaufen willst, dann ist das ganz nice, aber für sonst kann man es eigentlich
so gut wie vergessen.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Vielleicht ist ja doch irgendwas dabei, aber ich bezweifle es irgendwie.
Bei Amazon, guck mal hier, kaum ein paar Sachen fürs Fahrrad gekauft, zack, werden mir irgendwelche
Pedale empfohlen.
Ich bin übelste Arsch, Leute.
Und morgen, morgen muss ich nach Frankfurt fahren.
Ich habe eigentlich gar keinen Bock.
Das Beste ist morgen, dass ich zu Mexikaner fressen gehen kann und ich gehe, und ich gehe
wahrscheinlich mittags ne Runde zum Friseur, aber das Beste morgen ist, dass ich zu Mexikaner
was futtern kann.
Also, ansonsten ist das ja eigentlich total unsinnig, aber ich will mich mal nicht beschweren,
ja.
Einmal die Woche ist vollkommen in Ordnung und hätten die bei der alten Arbeit das auch
so gesehen, wäre ich wahrscheinlich immer noch da.
Wie war das Essen heute?
Ja, ich habe Ente mit Erdnusssoße gefuttert, war nice.
Hab ich heute bestellt, aber nicht bestellt, so Lieferando-mäßig, sondern angerufen und
hingegangen, der ist nicht so weit weg.
Heute Morgen wieder Rennen gewesen, 6,2 Kilometer in 6 Minuten 30.
Nicht super High Speed, sondern so, dass ich noch gut schnaufen konnte.
Wenn man sich überlegt, das ist schon richtig krass schnell geworden.
Das erste Mal, wo ich gerannt bin, hatte ich 8 Minuten 50 pro Kilometer und mir hat alles
wehgetan und war übelst anstrengend.
Und jetzt renne ich 6 Minuten 30 ohne, dass es mich groß schockt.
Ja, war die beste Idee.
War wirklich die beste Idee.
Und ich wäre ja fast woanders gelandet, hätte mich nicht ein Kollege noch angeschrieben.
Letztendlich bin ich froh, dass ich da gelandet bin.
Das ist bei mir um die Ecke, nice Homeoffice-Regelung, ordentlich Kohle, nette Leute, natürlich
paar hast du ein bisschen rumgezackert immer, aber ist ja nichts Schlimmes.
Auch vom Inhalt her nice, ich kann Sachen machen, worauf ich Bock habe.
Ich kriege jetzt übrigens, hat mir letztens mein Chef erzählt, ich kriege jetzt einfach
250 Euro im Monat mehr, so random, so bam, by the way, du kriegst jetzt auch, äh nicht
650, 250, du kriegst jetzt einfach 250 Euro mehr im Monat, so okay, nice, gg.
Das ist für den Fall der Fälle, also dass man auf einer Liste steht mit Leuten, die
eventuell angerufen werden, wenn was ist.
Auf der stehe ich dann zwar drauf, aber juckt mich nicht, weil ich bin nicht verpflichtet
dran zu gehen und da zu sein, das Einzige, wo ich verpflichtet bin, dran zu gehen und
da zu sein, ist, wenn ich explizit eingeteilt bin für, man muss nachts erreichbar sein
innerhalb von, was heißt nachts, das ist glaube ich von 17 Uhr bis 6 Uhr oder sowas, ne von
18 Uhr bis 7 Uhr ist das und die Zeit kriegt man ja auch nochmal extra bezahlt, man hat
glaube ich ne Stunde Reaktionsteil, also es ist easy, heute Nacht übrigens auch, also
ich hab hier das Handy von einer Firma gegenüber liegen, also wenn das klingelt, dann muss
ich dran gehen und den Stream ausmachen, weil da ist irgendwas kaputt gegangen, aber es
kommt sehr, sehr selten vor und das gibt nochmal richtig Kohle, Leute, ich weiß nicht, was
mit denen los ist, aber die geben gerne Geld aus, aber die geben Geld aus an der richtigen
Stelle, nämlich für die Leute, die dort arbeiten.
Ich musste vor 2 oder 3 Wochen, ihr erinnert euch doch noch daran, wo ich nicht so richtig
streamsen konnte am Wochenende und alles, da war ja ein groß geplanter Test bei mir
auf der Arbeit, das ging dann quasi den ganzen Samstag mit Unterbrechung und inklusive Bereitschaft,
Rufbereitschaft erreichbar sein bis Montag 7 Uhr und ein Kollege von mir hat das ausgerechnet,
das bringt über 1000 Euro, nur diese, ja, zweieinhalb Tage, über 1000 Euro, ist schon
krass, oder?
Die wollen es einfach echt wissen, ich beschwere mich nicht, ich werde ab jetzt immer bei irgendwelchen
Tests mitmachen am Samstag, wenn das so viel Kohle bringt, aber ist schon heftig, gut,
teilweise natürlich mit Steuern, aber ich glaube nicht alles mit Steuern, weil ich glaube
solche Samstags- und Schichtzuschläge und sowas, die sind teilweise auch steuerfrei,
da weiß ich aber nicht genau, wie sich das verhält, ich weiß es nur vom Ex-Kollege
auf der anderen Arbeit, der hatte zwar in reinen Summen kein so gutes Gehalt, aber dadurch,
dass der total viel Nachtschicht und so gearbeitet hat und das war alles steuerfrei, der hat
zwar in der Summe nicht so viel draufstehen gehabt, aber hat trotzdem unterm Strich mehr
gekickt als ich, also sieht man mal, wie viel das ausmacht, die Nacht ist dazwischen, zwischen
18 und 7 Uhr, aber das ist so, wie wenn du sagen würdest, 0 bis 16 Uhr, ja, da ist Mittagessen,
das ist viel zu wenig, dafür würde ich das nicht machen, 7 Tage, 24 Stunden Erreichbarkeit
da hast du ja am Ende 150 Euro mehr, dafür würde ich das nicht machen, das ist viel zu wenig,
also dafür würde ich mich nicht einschränken, ihr habt ja sicherlich auch Reaktion, was habt ihr
für eine Reaktionszeit, also meistens haben die irgendwas um eine Stunde, die hoffen natürlich,
die hoffen natürlich, dass die Leute schneller an den Rechner oder ans Telefon gehen, wie ist
bei euch die Reaktionszeit, also dafür würde ich das nicht machen, dafür würde ich mich nicht
einschränken, da kannst du nämlich nicht irgendwo mal hin wandern gehen oder so, das ist kacke,
also das würde ich nicht machen für das Geld, da müssen sie schon ein bisschen was dranhängen,
also bei mir sind sie da aber echt großzügig, finde ich sehr nice, deswegen machen es die Leute
dort wahrscheinlich auch und sind allgemein deutlich besser drauf als bei der alten Arbeit,
wer hätte das gedacht Leute, kaum bezahlst du deine Leute ordentlich, schon sind die besser drauf,
damit hätte man ja gar nicht rechnen können oder, ich meine mehr Geld oder Obstkorb und
Kickertisch, was ist den Leuten wohl lieber, na gut, wenn du irgendwelche Startups fragst,
dann wahrscheinlich Kickertisch, aber realistisch betrachtet ist den Leuten wahrscheinlich mehr
Geld lieber, anstatt Obstkorb und Kickertisch, beim Provider, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht
habe, da haben sie auch damals groß erzielt, oh wir haben einen Kickertisch und wisst ihr,
immer wenn ich das Wort Kickertisch höre, frage ich mich, so Max, bist du eigentlich der
einzige auf der Welt, der Tischkicker spielen total dumm findet und langweilig und überhaupt
keinen Bock drauf hat, weiß nicht, wie geht das euch, habt ihr Bock auf Tischkicker spielen,
ich mache das so, ich mache das komplett ungern, dementsprechend, ich meine ich kann das auch nicht,
weil ich das, für mich ist das so mein Nullbonus, dass es einen Tischkicker Tisch gibt,
ich meine, so ein Ding kostet auch wahrscheinlich bei AliExpress 50 Euro,
auch keinen Bock, das verstehe ich auch, eine Runde im Jahr, gut, das halte ich vielleicht
auch noch aus, aber viel Bock habe ich nicht drauf, ja die ganzen krassen Agile Startups
brauchen das, seid ihr in Bayern, ist in Bayern Bier nicht Grundnahrungsmittel und
jeder dürfte sich besaufen auf der Arbeit, wobei ich weiß nicht, ob ich da die richtigen Schlüsse
draus gezogen habe, ob das so stimmt, aber bei den Bayern weiß man nie so genau, bei den Bayern
regelt der Markt das jetzt auch nicht mehr, die FDP ist raus, habe ich gelesen nach der Wahl,
in Hessen, in Hessen, dank meiner Stimme, haben sie es gerade so geschafft auf 5 Prozent, aber
ganz ganz close, ganz knapp, so das können wir alles mal zumachen, das interessiert ja hier gar
nicht, wobei wir machen einfach Amazon auf, nein wir machen Amazon hier garantiert nicht auf,
wir machen Amazon hier auf, weil das ist viel zu hell, da bist du ja geblendet, so Prime Deals,
also ich werde wahrscheinlich irgendwelchen Random Shit kaufen am Ende wieder, aber wirklich
sinnvolles wird es nicht geben, welche Distro würdest du für Entwickler empfehlen, die von
Linux auf Mac wechseln wollen, naja wenn du von, Moment, von Mac auf Linux wechseln suchst,
starte doch mal mit Linux Mint, so wie jeder andere auch, weil du hast mit Mac schon mal
einen riesen Vorteil gegenüber Windows Usern, du kennst dich ein bisschen, du kannst zumindest
Bash oder ZSH oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung schon mal halbwegs bedienen, warum willst du
eigentlich wechseln von Mac auf Linux, so würde mich mal interessieren, weil viele Mac Leute sind
ja so richtig eingefleischte Mac User, die, die, die schwören so, ich schwöre auf Mac machen die,
für alles, wir haben auch so ein paar Consulting Leute da, aber die sind hauptsächlich so aus dem
BWL Projektmanagement Bereich und sowas, das ist ja auch so typische typische Mac User alles,
ich würde sagen, nimm Linux Mint, so wie jeder oder wie viele, die umsteigen von Windows oder
von woanders her, guck dir das erstmal an und wenn dir das gefällt und du gut mit klarkommst und
denkst, ich würde gerne noch mehr customisen, ich würde gerne noch mehr selbst machen,
dann nimmst du Arch Linux, das ist so die, das ist so die Progression, Einstieg Linux Mint,
danach, wenn man, wenn man zum Hardcore Linux User werden will, Arch Linux und manche verrückten
Leute machen dann auch sowas wie Gentoo oder sowas, kriegst du irgendein, kriegst du irgendein
Office Dokument im E-Mail Anhang, ist eh eine blöde Idee das aufzumachen, aber nur mal so,
kriegst du irgendein Office Dokument im E-Mail Anhang, musst du erstmal 40 Minuten im Office
kompilieren, kaum mal mit Mac überhaupt nicht klar, hatte letztens, ich auch, ich habe es auch
mal ausprobiert auf so einer, auf so einer ollen Mini PC Kiste mit irgendeinem Custom Bootloader
und sowas, ich bin, ich bin mit den, mit den Control und Alt und Mac Taste und so, da bin ich
überhaupt nicht klar gekommen. Ja Mr. Robot, erzähl doch mal, warum willst du, ach du hast schon,
hast schon, man merkt einfach immer, dass man eingeschränkt ist, ja was Customization angeht,
ist glaube ich unter Mac nicht, nicht so weit, nicht so weit her. Zumindest ist das coole an Mac,
solange man es mal auf Command Line beschränkt, ist ja deutlich angenehmer schon mal als Windows.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, probier mal, probier mal Linux Mint aus, das, das schwören ja viele
rauf als, als Einsteigerbetriebssystem und du hast einen riesen Vorteil gegenüber Windows
Umsteigern, du kennst dich schon ein bisschen im Terminal und mit Bash oder mit ZSH aus,
das heißt du kommst da auch viel besser mit klar, wenn du mal was auf der Kommandozeile machen
musst und ich finde es gerade auf Linux, gerade auf der Linux ist natürlich auch sinnvoll, was in der
Kommandozeile zu machen, weil die eben gut ist, im Vergleich zu dem, was Windows jahrelang
ausgeliefert hat, immer noch ausliefert. Ich meine PowerShell ist nice, aber PowerShell ist nicht
gut für interaktiv drin arbeiten. Wieso machst du in der Uhr, ist das, ja da gibt's sogar ein, da
gibt's sogar ein Chat, Chat Kommando für, gibt sogar Chat. Deine Meinung zu OSINT, keine Ahnung,
ist irgendein Hacking-Kram oder sowas, wenn ich, ich habe gerade mal gesucht danach, ist das sowas
wie Browser Fingerprinting oder was ist das? Keine Ahnung, da habe ich keine Meinung zu, sagt mir
nix. Ach hier gibt's ja, hier hat schon jemand den Befehl gepostet, genau, da habe ich das erklärt mit
dem Copy-Pasten. Ja es ist, es ist, hier Leute, also Art-Schildungs-Installieren ist mittlerweile
tatsächlich relativ easy. Lass, lass dich nicht, lass dich nicht gebaten von irgendwelchen Wiki-Artikeln,
wie Art-Schildungs-Manuell installiert wird. Du kannst es bei mir im Archive angucken, wie ich
das installiert habe in AVM. Das ist mit dem Arch-Installer oder Arch-Setup heißt, glaube ich,
ist das total easy. Bootest du als Live, vom Live-Stick Arch-Setup und fertig oder Arch-Install,
ja und klickst den Installer durch, beziehungsweise klicken ist das falsche Wort, du, du, du drückst
den Installer durch, geklickt wird er nicht. PowerShell oder Slow as Fuck, ja gut, das basiert
auf .NET, das starten muss, ist logischerweise langsam, aber danach geht's doch. Aha. Meinung
zu Custom-Keyboards, ehrlich gesagt habe ich da keine Meinung, soweit ich kein Custom-Keyboard
habe. Ich habe mir da auch, habe ich mir bis jetzt auch noch nicht gewünscht oder mich näher mit
beschäftigt. Ich hatte auf der alten Arbeit einen Kollegen, der hat, der hat total drauf geschwört,
der hatte auch gefühlt irgendwie in zwei Jahren fünf verschiedene Tastaturen. Das weiß ich,
weil er die hat, die hat er immer, hat er immer gezeigt, hat gesagt, Max, guck mal,
ich habe eine neue, ich habe eine neue Tastatur und der hatte so auch, der hatte auch so Mini-Keyboards,
also nicht wirklich Mini-Keyboards, sondern so diese, wie nennt man das, ohne Num-Block und
dann noch ohne, ohne diese Spalte, wo Home, Home-Taste, End-Taste, Bild hoch und Bild runter
und genau 60% Tastatur, genau sowas meine ich. Und dann, da stand er total drauf. Der hat auch
Custom, Custom-Knöpfe gehabt und alles mögliche. Ich, ich habe, ich persönlich habe die Faszination
daran nicht wirklich verstanden. Ich habe jetzt hier schon seit einer ganzen Weile so eine Logitech
Tastatur, selbstverständlich mit RGB-Beleuchtung, weil mehr FPS, kann man sich nicht entgehen lassen,
genauso wie RAM-Beleuchtung, also, also RGB auf, auf, auf dem Arbeitsspeicher ist wirklich das
Essentiellste überhaupt und ich habe bei diesem Rechnerkauf ja wieder den Fehler gemacht, ein
Gehäuse zu nehmen mit Glaswand und ich gucke da nie rein. Ich kann auch nicht mal richtig reingucken,
weil ungefähr 80% von der Seitenwand sind mit einem Gehäuse zugestellt, was daneben steht,
aber ich kann so schräg reingucken, ich kann so schräg reingucken und sehe meine zwei RAM-Riegel
RGB-technisch pulsieren. Nice. So, jetzt gucke ich nicht mehr rein. Das, also RGB ist für mich echt
sowas. Ich finde das immer nice und wenn ich das, wenn ich das kaufe irgendwie und dann gucke ich
dann die letzten, die nächsten paar Jahre, wenn ich den Rechner habe, nicht mehr rein. Ja, nice,
schön, dass du da bist. Du hast letztens schon mal was geschrieben, ne? Dass du hier den WCher
gefunden hast. Ja, du bist nicht der Einzige. Also, wir haben, wir haben jede Menge ehemalige
Call-of-Duty-Kinder hier im, im Stream. Sogar manche Modgis. Ist ein US-Layout besser zum
Programmieren? Also, in der reinen Lehre wahrscheinlich, ja, weil du so Sachen wie
eckige Klammer auf und zu auf ordentlichen Tasten hast, aber die Umgewöhnung ist es mir nicht wert.
Also, wenn du nicht schon, wenn du nicht schon an irgendwas gewöhnt bist, dann kannst du es mit
US-Layout machen, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn du das deutsche Tastatur-Layout gewöhnt bist,
ich finde es lohnt sich nicht sich umzugewöhnen. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die machen nicht US-Layout,
die machen nicht, wie heißt das? Es gibt auch so ein, so ein spezielles Programmier-Tastatur-Layout,
was auch manche, was auch manche haben. Da, da schwören die auch dann komplett drauf. Dumm ist
nur, wenn du dich mal an irgendeinen anderen Rechner setzen musst, um was zu tippen, du kriegst
halt gar nichts mehr auf die Reihe. Das ist ein bisschen so, ist ein bisschen so, wie, wie die
Russen, die wir früher auf der Arbeit hatten. Die haben immer irgendwie russisches Tastatur-Layout
gehabt und jedes Mal, wenn ich, wenn, wenn die gesagt haben, hier, guck mal, probier mal zu tippen
und so, da mussten die immer erst mal Tastatur-Layout umschalten, weil ich ansonsten irgendwelche
komischen russischen Dinger getippt habe. Der Sibaro, gibt's den auch noch? Ich muss mal kurz
in Discord reingucken, warte mal. Wenn, wenn, wenn der Ober-Cute-Mod was schreiben will, dann gucke
ich da auch mal rein. Wo ist er eigentlich? War schon lange nicht mehr da, oder? Hyper-Cute-Mod.
Oh, hier haben viele geschrieben, in Mods. Hier. Ah, der Sibaro hat den Archive-Surfer
upgradet. So. Ja, also Archive-Surfer zieht demnächst um, kriegt mehr Bandbreite und fettere Kisten.
Num-Block, ich brauche Num-Block. Ich habe am liebsten so eine Full-Size-Tastatur mit allem
drauf. Also ich mag, ich mag Num-Block auf Tastatur, auf der, an der Tastatur gar nicht mal so sehr
wegen hier den, wegen den Nummern. Ich mag Num-Block wegen der Enter-Taste auf dem Num-Block. Ich habe
irgendwie so eine Angewohnheit. Ich, ich, ich weiß nicht woran das liegt, aber ich habe, ich habe so
eine Angewohnheit und das habe ich seit Jahren schon. Ich habe zwei Sachen, wie ich einen Befehl abschicken
kann. So, ich kann entweder sagen LSLA Enter, also wenn ich mir, wenn ich mir sicher bin, wenn ich mir
sicher bin, dann sieht das so aus. Dann ist das, dann ist das alles easy. Gucken wir mal, ob die startet das Ding
jetzt schnell. Vor allem wäre es wieder High-Speed. Ja, das habe ich gemeint, genau. Dvorak, Schweiz,
Moment, die haben ein eigenes Tastatur-Layout. Haben die das? Patrick, bist du da? Haben die,
haben die Schweizer ein eigenes Tastatur-Layout? Nee, ich habe es, ich habe es schon gefunden.
An das Trinken erinnern. Ja, Pog. Also, hier Num-Block, was ich, was ich meine ist folgendes,
was ich meine ist folgendes. Also, ab dem ich sehe, wenn ich mir sicher bin, was ich eintippe,
dann mache ich das ganz normal. Dann wird getippt hier und normal Enter gedrückt. Aber,
wenn ich ein bisschen was Komplizierteres bastle, ja, also sagen wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel sowas
hier. So, und das muss ich mir nochmal angucken. Dann gucke ich mir das nochmal an, aber dann,
fragt mich nicht warum, keine Ahnung, aber wenn ich mir das angucke, ja doch, ich weiß warum,
ich weiß warum. Weil ich, weil ich immer mit den, weil ich keine Ruhe habe beim Tippen. Nee,
noch nicht du, wir haben nicht mal angefangen. Ich immer mit den Arrow-Keys sinnlos drin rumtippen
muss. Und dann, wenn ich es mir durchgelesen habe, dann hämmer ich die Enter-Taste am Num-Block. So,
um ein bisschen längere, kompliziertere Befehle abzuschicken, die ich nochmal durchlesen muss,
die bestätige ich immer mit dem Num-Block. Macht keinen Sinn, mache ich aber so. Ja,
und dann kommen zum Beispiel solche ganz furchtbar super, super wichtigen Sachen raus,
wie zum Beispiel das hier. Das haben wir, das haben wir schon immer mal gebraucht. Das war
enorm, also wirklich essentiell, dass ich mir den Befehl im Vorfeld nochmal durchgelesen habe.
Oh, das verursacht aber ganz schön CPU-Last, ja. Ja, immerhin, immerhin 30% CPU-Last. Gut.
So sieht es aus. Ja, für IPs ist es tatsächlich auch ganz nice. Wobei, schade, dass es keinen
Punkt auf dem Num-Block gibt. Gibt es ja nur so ein dummes Komma. Ich habe drei Wochen lang nicht
meine Bude aufgeräumt und bin so überfordert. Viel Spats, any tips? Ja, lass sie einfach weiter
nicht aufgeräumt. Easy, gelöst. Lifehack. Ja, mit IPv6, dann bringt dir der Num-Block nichts mehr.
Ja, oder du nimmst den Tastaturtreiber hier und stellst es um. Aber mit IPv6 musst du doch gar
nichts mehr tippen. Mit IPv6 kannst du doch alles Doppelpunkt machen. Nee, Doppelpunkt darfst du
nur einmal pro Adresse machen. Die Regelung, die Regelung habe ich bis heute nicht gecheckt,
wann man Doppelpunkt machen darf und in IPv6 und wann nicht. Ich glaube, man darf einmalig
pro IPv6-Block, egal wo man will, abkürzen mit einem Doppelpunkt, aber nur einmalig.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es bis heute nicht wirklich kapiert. Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt gibt es nur
einmal. Irgendwie sowas, genau. Ich habe mich da ehrlich gesagt auch lange nicht mal mit
beschäftigt. Okay, also let's go. Dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Wo haben wir es denn hier?
So, wetten, dass es nichts Gescheites gibt. Warum habe ich noch 964 Euro im Einkaufskorb? Ah ja,
ja gut, das ist ja mittlerweile schon alles durch. Habe ich, okay, habe ich bestellt. Habe ich nicht
bestellt, weil meine alte Waage wieder funktioniert. Einfach random geht die wieder. Letztes Mal war
sie noch kaputt und Batterien rein und raus habe ich schon gemacht, bevor mir jetzt irgendeiner
kommt und sagt, Max, hast du auch schon mal rebooted? Ja klar, habe ich rebooted, aber aus
irgendwelchen Gründen geht die wieder, soll mir recht sein. Habe ich auch bestellt, war ein guter
Tipp-Chat. Ich weiß nicht, wer es genau empfohlen hat, aber ich finde das ein nice System. Ich habe
jetzt auch so ein Clip-Ding für die Trinkflasche dran. Die Handschuhe habe ich tatsächlich auch
bestellt, die gefallen mir aber nicht. Die sind zu dick gepolstert. Habe ich bestellt. Die GoPro
habe ich auch bestellt. Ich habe sie heute ans Fahrrad montiert, die GoPro. T-Shirts habe ich
auch bestellt. Eine Brille habe ich auch bestellt. Die ist tatsächlich nice. Das ist so eine Brille,
die automatisch den Grad der Tönung anpasst, wie dunkel es wird, je nach Sonneneinstrahlung.
Das ist sehr praktisch. Klingel habe ich auch bestellt. Reflektor-Dinger habe ich auch bestellt.
Rücklicht habe ich auch bestellt. Katzen-Ergänzungs-Zeug habe ich auch bestellt.
Katzen-Zeug habe ich auch bestellt. Für später gesichert. Brauchen wir nicht. Löschen. Nice,
GG. Alles durch. Also, da wollen wir noch mal. Fahrrad-Content. Ich habe mir überlegt,
ich schneide mir meine GoPro aufs Fahrrad, wenn ich das nächste Mal rumfahre. Ein bisschen in
der Landschaft. Und nehme einfach mal was auf für den Video-Hintergrund. Weil wenn ich mal wieder
ein paar Videos mache, ist das zumindest eine, sagen wir mal, eine ganz nette Option. Mach mal
Ausrufenzeichen Fahrrad. Da gibt es ein Kommando für schon. Oder Rad. Ich dachte,
das ist Ausrufenzeichen Fahrrad. Oder Ausrufenzeichen Bike. Fahrrad. Genau das da ist es
hier. Gucken wir mal, ob es im Vorschau funktioniert. Ja, ist da. Ja, und ich dachte mir,
das ist ganz gut der Hintergrund. Ganz gut der Hintergrund-Content. Warte ich mal,
bis gutes, bis schönes Wetter ist. Fahre ein bisschen hier durch die Felder und lasse einfach
mal die Kamera mitlaufen. Ja, nice, nice Fahrrad. Ja, Fahrrad-Stelz. Schneestelz hat die Welt
anscheinend laut YouTube-Algorithmus drauf gewartet. Vielleicht wartet die Welt auch
auf Fahrrad-Stelz. Man kann bei YouTube nie wissen. Also, Prime-Day-Deals. Wow-Angebote.
Elefant-Roboter. Elefant-Roboter. Saug-Roboter. Locken. Oh ja, das brauche ich unbedingt.
WLAN-Mesh-Router. Ne, das brauche ich nicht. So, also, zeigt mal her. Blitzangebote,
juckt jetzt nicht. Computer und Software ist meistens nur... Ne, Moment, die haben die
Kategorien wieder geändert. Hatten die nicht mal eine Smart Home? Ah, nein,
es heißt jetzt Intelligentes Zuhause. Die haben das umbenannt. Meint ihr,
ist es wirklich so sinnvoll für Amazon, das umzubenennen? Niemand sagt Intelligentes Zuhause,
jeder sagt Smart Home. Ich meine, vielleicht die Oma um die Ecke nicht, aber die Oma um die Ecke
interessiert sich auch nicht für Smart Home. Bier, Wein und Spirituosen. Ne, könnte mich jagen mit
Beeren. Zum Glück nicht. Das hört der mal wieder gar nicht auf. Hat das jetzt funktioniert? Ne,
das hat wieder nicht richtig funktioniert, oder? Intelligentes Zuhause, doch, hat richtig
funktioniert. NFC-Tags. Hast du dir gekauft? Ja, NFC-Tags kosten halt 3,50 Euro. Um ein Prime
Deal wahrscheinlich dann 2,90 oder so. Soundcore. Was ist Soundcore? Ist das irgendeine Soundbar
für den Fernseher, oder? Lass uns mal kurz checken, ob es für Smart Home irgendwas gibt,
was halbwegs interessant ist. So, Netzwerk, Wifi-Lösung, AVM und so, das ist relativ
uninteressant. Die ganzen Dinger sind auch uninteressant, weil das irgendwelche proprietären
Sachen und Protokolle und wo man Apps braucht und so sind, kann man eigentlich auch alles mehr oder
weniger vergessen. Also für mich, solange ich es nicht easy in Home Assistant integrieren kann,
am besten über ZigBee oder meinetwegen auch Meta oder so was oder Wifi. Wobei Meta ist ja das
Protokoll und nicht die Übertragung. Dann ist mir das nix. Und Bosch Do-It-Yourself-Gartenartikel.
Das mache ich mal auf, vielleicht sehen wir was Spannendes dabei. Moment, was hat das denn bitte
schon mit intelligentes Zuhause? Was genau hat eine Koch-Amazon, please. Was hat eine Pfanne mit
intelligentem Zuhause zu tun? Und eine Mülltonne. Nein, ein Feuchtigkeitskiller. Moment, ist das ein
Katzenklo? Das ist doch ein Katzenklo, oder? Ne. Sowas ähnliches wie ein Katzenklo. Sieht aus wie
ein geschlossenes Katzenklo. Oh, MonkaKnife. Okay, Shelly-Sachen sind im Angebot. Das kann man sich
tatsächlich mal angucken. Smarte Beleuchtung, je nachdem was die für Anbieter haben, könnte auch
ganz nice sein. Smart und hocheffiziente Beleuchtung. Okay, Philips Hue ist einfach
wieder mega überteuert, auch in Prime Deals. Eufy. Früher dachte ich vom Namen her Eufy,
das klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen norwegisch oder so, aber ist es gar nicht. Ich glaube Eufy
ist Anker und Anker ist China-Chinesen-Kram. Noch mehr Shelly. Alo kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Home Improvement. Guck mal, die konnten das noch nicht mal mit Leerzeichen schreiben. Home Improvement
Products bei Meros. Die taugen leider auch nichts mehr, seitdem sie kein ESP32 mehr drin haben,
dementsprechend nicht mehr flashbar sind. Braucht man nicht. Braucht man nicht. Alles
proprietärer Kram hier, da braucht man nicht. Braucht man nicht. Inr, der Name triggert mich
schon. Wisst ihr was mich das erinnert? Inr, das erinnert mich vom Namen her an diesen komischen
Telekom Messenger. Kennt das noch irgendjemand? Die Telekom hat vor 5, 6 Jahren oder noch länger,
die Telekom macht ja öfter so irgendwelche tollen übertriebenen Ankündigungen, die wollten eine
WhatsApp Konkurrenz rausbringen, die super toll und jeder benutzen sollte und super geil ist,
nannte sich Immer von der Telekom und ist mittlerweile schon wieder eingestellt. 2016.
Und man hat damals schon jeder, also jeder mit ein bisschen verstanden hat damals schon gesagt,
Alter, das wird doch nix. Aber die Telekom hat sich gedacht, doch, aber seit 4, 5 Jahren ist
es wieder weg. Kann sich keiner mehr dran erinnern, weil logischerweise niemand mitbekommen. Aber es
war auch so ein Telekom Fail. Guck mal, dieser Sensor sieht aus wie ein, wie heißen die Sensoren?
DT 2018 oder sowas? Was ist das denn? Was bin ich denn hier sehend? Inkbird. Was ist das?
Thermos, WLAN, Thermostat, Heizung, Kühlung, Steckdose, Thermostat. Hä? Ich hab legit keine
Ahnung, was das ist. Chat, das könnt ihr für sowas benutzen, aber dafür bestimmt ganz schön teuer.
Was soll das sein? Smart Home, Smart Life. Ja, schön, aber was ist es denn? Smart Controller.
Aber was kontrollt es denn? Die Steckdosen? Hä? Ich verstehe es nicht. Suchen Sie nach dem
Schlüsselwort Inkbird Smart. Nee, ich will doch nur wissen, was es ist. Chris, danke schön für
den Sub. Ich will einfach nur verstehen, was es ist. Intelligenter Thermostat zum Kühlen und
Heizen. Hä? Ich verstehe es immer noch nicht. PVSV? Rotes Licht leuchtet. Das ist ja schon mal
gut zu wissen, dass rotes Licht leuchtet und grünes Licht leuchtet auch, Leute. Und grünes
Licht blinkt. Boah, ist das geil. Das brauche ich. Ich meine, rotes und grünes blinkendes Licht,
warum nicht 250 mit einem ESP, wenn man auch 40 Euro für ausgeben kann? Ach, jetzt verstehe ich,
was das ist. Das ist im Prinzip, sagen wir mal, ein Relay mit einer Temperatursonde und ich kann
einstellen, dass es quasi die Steckdosen daran schaltet, ein und aus, anhand der Umgebungstemperatur.
So eine Art Zeitschaltuhr mit Temperatursensor, ja? Was das hier mit... Das ist wahrscheinlich...
Aber Heating und Cooling verstehe ich jetzt nicht so genau, warum es da zwei Funktionen... Ach so,
zwei Steckdosen. Okay, bei dem einen Überschreiten der Temperatur geht das Cooling, geht, keine Ahnung,
die obere Steckdose an, beim Unterschreiten der Temperatur geht der Heizer. Ja, das ist ja super
kompliziert, Alter. Ja, na gut. Ich meine, wenn man sowas wirklich Standalone braucht, ist das
eventuell gar nicht mal so mies. Für meinen Anwendungszweck ist das natürlich komplett
unsinnig, weil ich habe jede Menge Steckdosen im Haus, die ich WiFi-mäßig schalten kann und ich
habe auch an den Räumen, wo es mich interessiert, Thermostate drinnen und könnte so einfach easy
drauf reagieren, wenn ich das will. Aber dazu habe ich in den wichtigen Räumen, an den Heizkörpern
ja auch Thermostate und die gehen auch automatisch... Also die gehen morgens um 8 Uhr an und jetzt heute
23 Uhr gehen sie aus. Also nicht aus, auf den Low-Modus. Und wenn ich eine Automatisierung
von Hand anklicke, wenn Sommer wird, dann gehen die alle in den Sommer-Modus und die Heizung im
Keller wird ausgeschaltet. Also insofern, das ist wirklich extremely unsinnig. Aber okay,
für manche ist das vielleicht ganz nice. Next. Was ist das denn? Safe? Thermostat für Heizung.
So ein Krempel ist heute echt beliebt anscheinend. Kennst du den Akara-Anwesenheitssensor? Ja,
der liegt neben mir, gerade auf dem Basteltisch. Hier ist er irgendwo. Wartet mal, hier. Akara...
Ach Moment, das ist das Falsche hier, was ich in der Hand habe. Hier, Akara-Presence-Sensor,
FP2. Kaufen? Keine Ahnung. Ich habe den gekauft, der ist ja gar nicht billig. Ich habe den gekauft,
weil ich ihn cool finde vom Produkt her, aber ich habe ihn noch nicht ausprobiert. Der liegt
original verpackt hier noch rum. Und ich kenne mich. So Smart-Home-Dinger kaufe ich schneller,
als ich sie ausprobieren kann. Heißt im Endeffekt, ich werde es wahrscheinlich nie
ausprobieren, so wie ich mich kenne. Oder doch, wenn ich mal meine 5 Minuten habe,
dann probiere ich das aus. Kaufen ist auch reduziert. Kann ich dir nicht sagen,
ich habe ihn nicht ausprobiert. Du brauchst auf jeden Fall die offizielle App dafür,
um den ins WLAN und so zu bekommen. Nuki-Set. Ich mag keine Smart-Logs. Für was hast du das
bestellt? Also ich bin, ich habe in meinem Haus hier sehr viel smartes Zeug. Von Steckdosen,
Beleuchtung, bis selbst gebaute Sachen, bis sogar ein automatisch steuerbares Ventil für
den Wasserdruck in meiner Heizung im Keller. Aber Smart-Logs habe ich bisher immer im Bogen drum
gemacht und bin ich auch kein Fan von. Ja nur, dass es kein Schrott ist. Irgendwann ist es mal
Schrott. Es wird quasi Schrott. Aber du kannst dir auf YouTube jede Menge Reviews dazu angucken.
Und ich habe mir den bestellt, weil das Fazit war, dass es ein ziemlich cooles Gadget ist,
oder ein ziemlich cooler Sensor ist, wenn man sowas braucht. Weil ich ab und zu schon
versehentlich ohne Schlüssel aus der Wohnung bin. Okay, ja, das ist auch eine Möglichkeit. Ich habe
halt bei diesen ganzen Smart-Logs immer so ein bisschen Bedenken. Das erste ist, was passiert,
wenn die Batterie alle ist. Ich glaube, da verhält sich jedes ein bisschen anders. Für die meisten
musst du wahrscheinlich manuell irgendwie entriegeln. Ich hoffe, keines davon geht einfach
auf. Aber wo ich mir viel mehr Gedanken drüber mache, diese Smart-Log-Sachen hatten in der
Vergangenheit teilweise schon wirklich horrende Sicherheitslücken. Erinnert sich noch einer daran,
es könnte sogar Nuki gewesen sein. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, welcher Smart-Log-Hersteller
es war. Da gab es eine Invite-a-Friend-Funktion über die App. Und man konnte diesen Invite-a-Friend-Link
erraten. Relativ easy. Sodass man sich in das Home inviten konnte mit seinem eigenen Smartphone,
ohne dass man von dem Besitzer des Hauses invited wurde. Also, das sind so Dinge, da mache ich mir
über Smart-Logs schon ein bisschen Gedanken. Es könnte Ring gewesen sein, Nuki, ich weiß es nicht
mehr. Ist auch schon ein paar Jährchen her. Wenn alles lokal ist, ohne jegliche Cloud-Unterstützung,
dann könnte ich es mir vielleicht vorstellen. Aber ganz im Ernst, an der Haustür würde ich es
trotzdem nicht machen. Da bin ich vielleicht zu Boomer oder zu Oldschool. Smart-Logs, vielleicht
ganz nice Sache für ganz spezielle Anwendungsgebiete, aber für die Haustür, ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie
ist mir das nix. Und wenn es einem nix ist, ist es meistens besser, man lässt es bleiben. Weil
sollte dann was damit sein, dass irgendwie was nicht funktioniert oder irgendwas kacke läuft,
ärgert man sich doppelt. Nicht nur, weil es kacke gelaufen ist, sondern weil man schon immer
dachte, es ist eigentlich Mist. Lockpicking-Lawyer ist eh der Beste. To is binding, click of four
oder so in der Richtung. Was hat er immer? Irgendwas is binding, click out of four. Oder
was hat er noch so für Gespräche? Das gibt so drei, vier Sachen, das sagt er jedes Mal in jedem
Video fünfmal. Wir haben lange kein Lockpicking-Lawyer mehr geguckt. So, also was haben wir denn hier
schönes? Shelly. Nothing on X. Ja, genau. Nothing on 2. Das sagt er auch immer. Tension, ja. Also
was hat Shelly denn am Start? Shelly plus 2 PM, das sind die mit, ich glaub PM sind die, wo du
einen noch Strom messen kannst. Power Management oder was? Nee, nicht messen. Verbrauch, Verbrauch.
Zumindest so Pima Daumen auslesen. Okay, das ist wirklich so für einen Hausanschluss irgendwie.
Hab ich, hab ich noch nicht gemacht. Ich warte, bis ich irgendwann mal von den Stadtwerken irgendeinen
Smart Meter eingebaut kriege, wo man per WLAN was abgreifen kann oder per LED. So, dann haben wir
ein Shelly Dimmer, ein Shelly... Leute, das Ding sieht einfach mal original aus, wie der Acara-Sensor,
oder? Sagt doch mal. Nur, dass da Shelly draufsteht. Nein, nee, die Ecke, die Ecke, die Ecke nicht.
Nee, die Ecke nicht. Nee, auch die Batterieanzeige. Gut, ich mein, die Dinger sind alle ungefähr gleich
groß und haben die gleichen Sachen drauf, aber es hat schon, hat schon Feinheiten, die ein bisschen
anders sind, hauptsächlich die Ecke. Und ich glaube, das Display ist auch irgendwie andere Resolution.
Ist es nicht? Die Frage ist, ist es Wi-Fi oder ist es irgendwas Low-Energy-mäßiges? Wi-Fi! Also so ein
Ding mit Knopfzelle und Wi-Fi, das hält... Ach nee, das ist so ein großes Ding. Ach, das ist so ein
großes Ding. Aber mit Wi-Fi hält das doch wieder nur ein halbes Jahr oder sowas. Das ist doch over one
year. Naja, aber selbst das sagt halt, meine, der erste, Leute, mein allererster Acara-Temperatursensor
ist jetzt leergegangen und den habe ich bestellt. Ich sag euch das mal. Acara. Den habe ich bestellt.
Hm. Wo ist er denn? Hier, 5. April 2021. Das hat zweieinhalb Jahre gehalten jetzt mit einer Knopfzelle
der Acara-Sensor. Natürlich nur geflasht, also nur dank geflashter Custom-Firmware. Mit der offiziellen
Firmware wäre das am dreiviertel Jahr leer gewesen wahrscheinlich. Aber das hat sich richtig gelohnt,
das Ding. Die sind billig als fuck gewesen. Ich habe da dann später noch ein 10er-Pack bestellt
bei AliExpress für irgendwie 7 Euro das Stück. Oder noch weniger, 5 Euro. Das war mega billig. Also
nicht die. Wovon ich rede, sind die Dinger hier. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Der
Mustard. Die Dinger. Von den Dingern rede ich. Custom-Firmware geflasht über Bluetooth. Zweieinhalb
Jahre Laufzeit mit einer Knopfzelle. Richtig. Bogg. Kann man nicht anders sagen. So, was haben wir
denn sonst noch Schönes hier? Shelly, Shelly, Shelly. Shelly Motion. Shelly RGB. Shelly H&T
Weiß. Was soll denn das sein? Über was funken die? Bluetooth. BLE. Aber ich habe es halt hochgestellt,
dass sie nur alle Viertelstunde oder so funken und auch Sensoren seltener auslesen und dementsprechend
hält halt die Batterie richtig. Aber es reicht ja auch. Ganz ehrlich, wenn du den ganzen Tag
Temperatur in einem Raum ausliest, das reicht alle Viertelstunde. Das muss nicht alle 30 Sekunden sein
oder so, wie das die offizielle Firma macht. Luftfeuchtigkeits- und Temperatursensor. Das
ist ja hässlich. Da gibt es ja deutlich schickere, kleinere. So, weg damit. Das Beste für Zuhause.
Angebote für Beleuchtung und Smart Home. Jetzt kommt's. Okay, die Dinger brauche ich alle nicht.
Alles overrated, outdated, jebaited. Braucht man nicht. Oh, das sieht ja mal fancy aus. Selbst
drehen. Disco-Lichteffekte. RGB-Disco-Kugel. Na klar. Na klar. Das haben die alles genau so nur
mit einer Lampe beleuchtet. Selbstverständlich. Ja, genau. Und komisch, dass die die gleichen
Sachen alle abkriegen. Aber dann hast du die dänzenden Grills bei dir, sobald du die Lampe
am Start hast. Cool. Irgendwie ein cooles Selbstdrehen. Irgendwie finde ich das cool,
das Ding. Aber für 7,49 Euro ist es wahrscheinlich kompletter Schrott. So, weg. Was haben wir denn
sonst noch? Ist das ein Thermometer? Nee, nee. Ah, das ist eine LED mit LEDs ohne Verkleidung drum
rum oder sowas. Brauchen wir nicht. Brauchen wir nicht. Brauchen wir hier auch nicht. Brauchen
wir hier auch nicht. Alles weg. Weg. Alter, das sieht aus wie die Lampe von meiner Oma.
Wobei, so ein Ding hat nicht mal meine Oma mehr. So, was haben wir als nächstes? Hocheffiziente
Beleuchtung. Ach, guck mal. Ja, lass gucken. Guck mal gleich. Guck mal gleich mal bei Golem.
Schon wieder Nano Leafs. Nano Leafs sind meistens mega überteuert und das sind ja sogar einfach auch
nur LED Lichterketten mit sogar ziemlich weit auseinanderliegenden LEDs. Witz. Nano Leafs
übertrieben teuer. Nee, wir haben den. Wir haben 940 Euro aus dem Warenkorb gelöscht. Das haben
wir heute geschafft. Interessiert mich jetzt mal gar nicht. Warum sieht das aus wie Holz? Es sieht
nicht nur aus wie Holz. Es ist Holz. Holz, was lichtdurchlässig ist. Ein bisschen mit ein paar
LEDs dahinter. Naja, brauchen wir nicht. Weitere mega teure Nano Leafs, die jetzt ein bisschen
billiger sind, aber immer noch viel zu teuer. Aber 8 Seiten. 8 Seiten gucke ich mir da jetzt
bestimmt nicht an. Also wenn die ersten 2 Seiten nix dabei war, ist die Chance so gut, dass die
nächsten Seiten auch nix dabei sind. So, Shellys. Shellys hatten wir eben schon mal. Nix. Was haben
wir denn hier? Do it yourself. Home and Garden. Ah, grünes Bosch kommt mir nicht ins Haus. Ich
brauch das blaue. Ich muss mehr Geld ausgeben. Und dann einmal im Jahr benutzen. Also Küchen
Utensilien wollte ich mir jetzt eigentlich nicht kaufen. Also da war schon mal, was Smart Home
angeht, mehr oder weniger nix dabei. Dann haben wir hier noch, nee das ist die allgemeine Übersichtsseite
oder? Keine Ahnung, was das hier sein soll. Das ist nochmal der gleiche Shit. Ah guck mal,
hier gibt es die Bosch Professionals. Jetzt viel besser. Ich wollte nochmal gucken, was es bei
Computer gibt. Wobei wir haben ja gelernt, es heißt Computer. Ah ja, ok. SSDs und Speicher. Da
gibt es manchmal ganz gute Sachen. Also SSDs, dafür lohnt es sich oftmals. Und für Amazon
eigene Geräte. Ansonsten lohnt sich die ganze Prime Geschichte oftmals einfach gar nicht.
Laptops brauch ich nicht. Adobe Foto Abo. Ne? PC Komponenten im Angebot. Erstmal eine neue 4090
gönnen. Gibt es überhaupt noch SLI? Ich glaube SLI gibt es gar nicht mehr. Haben sie auch abgeschafft.
Anker. China-Chinesen-Kram. Let's go. Fire Tablet. Mal gucken, was die aktuell so kosten. Ich brauch
keins. Ich hab noch welche. Also an der Wand hängen und die gehen auch. Mini-PC Windows 11. Der sieht
echt hässlich aus. Wer hat sich dieses Design ausgedacht? Chatge, Frage an euch. Findet ihr
das Design schön oder findet ihr das Design eher blöd? Also schön oder hässlich? Oder jucht euch
nicht. Also ich persönlich finde es eher hässlich. Vor allem, was ich sehr unpraktisch finde ist,
du kannst es gar nicht flach hinlegen das Ding. Wegen der Form. Ja nice. Kann man Dota drauf
spielen. Super. Weil Dota auch das Game ist, was super krass Performance braucht. Und hier erkennt
man nicht mal, was es ist. Aber die Ausstattung scheint mir für irgendeine Emulator-Kiste und so
ganz brauchbar zu sein. Preislich keine Ahnung, ob das was taugt. So wir gucken uns mal kurz die
Empfehlungen an von Golem. Ob da irgendwas Spannendes, wo wir das ein bisschen abkürzen
können. Minisforum. Ich habe auch ein Minisforum Mini-PC. 99% Müll. Ja, so sieht es aus. Deswegen
sage ich doch. Overrated, outdated, debated. Outpaid. Nee, das geht nicht. Minisforum. Ja,
ich habe einen Max-11. Moment. Sowas habe ich hier. Geizhals? What's up? Ja, so einen habe
ich am Start. Minisforum UM96. Gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile auch schon bessere. Ist ja auch schon
wieder ein halbes Jahr oder dreiviertel Jahr alt. Aber der flutscht immer noch. Und man kann ihn zum
Glück auch hinlegen. Man braucht diesen komischen Stand nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich den Stand
dafür überhaupt habe. Also, was empfiehlt Golem denn? Ach nee, so schreiben die es sich. Also,
was haben wir? Was ich lohne? Eine Samsung-SSD mit Heatsink. Die sieht aber mal super advanced
aus. Gut, brauche ich nicht. Mein Mainboard hat ein Heatsink für die Onboard-SSD. Asus ROG Trix.
3000 Euro. Nee, 2049 Euro. Aber die ist nicht wirklich günstiger jetzt. Ah, die offizielle ist
ja auch schon weg. Jetzt ist nur noch der Woki als Verkäufer da. Kann die UM96 PS3 emulieren?
Habe ich im Video ausprobiert mit Uncharted und das lief nicht gut. Aber Uncharted ist
wahrscheinlich für Emulation auch so ziemlich eines der anstrengendsten Spiele überhaupt zu
emulieren. Lief nicht wirklich gut, Uncharted. Und der PS3-Emulator ist halt auch nicht so der
allerbeste. Aber prinzipiell kannst du damit PS3 emulieren. Aber ich glaube, für PS3-Emulation
wirst du damit nicht hundertprozentig glücklich. Aber Uncharted war auch schon echt eines der
härteren Tests. Tablets und Smartphones, Action-Cams, Dronen, Amazon-Produkte. Ja,
das lohnt sich eigentlich fast immer. Smartphone-Produkte. Haben wir gerade geguckt. Nix
dabei. Diverse Deals. Microsoft Office 365. Jawoll. Endlich. Okay, das könnte tatsächlich ganz
nützlich sein, wenn es die gibt mit Funkmodul. Sind die mit... Was bin ich sehend? Also manche
haben schon bescheuerte Werbebilder, oder? Was hat das mit einem Rauchmelder zu tun,
dass die da Flugzeug spielen? Rauchmelder? Also mich interessiert der mit RF-Modul. Das haben
die hier, glaube ich, gar nicht, oder? Ah ne, hier Funkrauchmelder, muss ich gucken. Äh,
das ist natürlich nicht reduziert. Das ist natürlich nicht reduziert. Ja,
so wirklich viel Spannendes war jetzt der Rechner dabei. Also zumindest hier. Lasst
uns mal kurz durchgucken, was aktuelle... Die sind auch in der ganzen Ecke teurer geworden.
Früher kosteten die immer 50 Euro oder 100 Euro. Auch das hat inflationiert. Aber die Dinger sind
halt kacke. Also ganz ehrlich, ich kann niemand ruhigen Gewissens empfehlen, für Daily, so als
Tablet-Driver ein Fire-Tablet zu nehmen. Die Dinger sind nur praktisch, also bei mir hier
zumindest, die Dinger sind nur praktisch für Dashboards, um sie an die Wand zu hängen. Ich
könnte mir vielleicht noch vorstellen, wenn das auf euch zutrifft, dass sowas vielleicht im
Wohnzimmer zu liegen, wenn man irgendwie besonders heavy im Amazon-Ökosystem drin ist, dass es noch
irgendwas bringt. Keine Ahnung bin ich nicht. Ich habe weder Alexa noch irgendwie Fire-Sticks
oder irgendwie Geschichten in der Richtung. Also für mich lohnt sich das nicht. Ich habe zwei
Fire-HD10s, die hängen bei mir an der Wand als Automation-Dashboard und fertig aus. Das ist aber
sehr kurz. Anker. Ein USB-Hub. Ich könnte tatsächlich noch ein USB-Hub gebrauchen.
Was machst du mit dem Dashboard? Zum Beispiel im Flur drauf gucken und feststellen, welche Tonne
raus auf die Straße muss oder gucken, wie die Außentemperatur ist oder bevor ich weggehe,
gucken, ob alle Fenster zu sind oder den Rollo mit runterfahren oder den Druck von der Heizung im
Keller einstellen. Also ein paar Sachen. Da ist mal ein ganz normales Home-Assistant-Dashboard drauf,
nur dass es halt im Flur hängt. Und es hat USB-C dran, also der Akku geht halt auch nicht
leer. Also ich könnte tatsächlich noch ein USB-Hub gebrauchen. Und genau den gleichen USB-Hub habe
ich auch schon. Da weiß ich, dass der für meine Anwendungszwecke auch funktioniert. Ich bräuchte
noch eine Powerbank. Sowas hat doch Anker auch. Da gucken wir mal, ob irgendwas Gescheites dabei
ist. Weil ich wollte eine kleine Powerbank eventuell mitnehmen, wenn ich längere Runden
mit dem Fahrrad mache. Man weiß ja nie. Sei es für die GoPro, falls ich da wirklich mal was mit
aufnehmen will. Fürs Handy, falls es leer geht. Fürs Navi, falls es leer geht. Für meine elektronische
Schaltung, falls sie leer gehen sollte. Random zwischendurch. Was? Ein internen USB-Hub? Wie
darf man sich sowas vorstellen? Das ist dann quasi eine Steckkarte zum Einbauen, die man an
USB anstöpselt und... Achso, einfach ein paar USB-Steckplätze für PCI-Express? Ja, das kenne
ich natürlich. Was ich sehr nice finde ist, wenn man sich in Nass bauen will, da gibt es mittlerweile
so Kombi-Geräte. Das ist eine PCI-Express-Karte. Die haben Platz für eine SSD und für einen
10-Gig-Netzwerkinterface. Sowas hier in der Richtung. Das finde ich ganz nice, wenn man
nämlich bei kleinen, sehr kompakten Kisten nur einen PCI-Express-Slot hat, der aber genug Lanes
bietet und man so eine 10-Gig und zwei SSDs dazu bekommt. Finde ich sehr nice. Da gibt es
mittlerweile mehr als nur die QNAP-Dinger. Graugier. So, also ein USB-Hub könnte ich
gebrauchen, tatsächlich. Dann ein USB-C-Ladegerät. Nee, das brauche ich nicht. Also ganz ehrlich,
USB-Kabel und Ladegeräte habe ich nur wirklich genug. Was ich gebrauchen könnte, wäre noch ein
weiteres Multilade-Kabel. Also so eins mit Micro-USB, USB-C und Lightning. Oder an einem
Kabel dann die drei Sachen. So eins könnte ich tatsächlich noch brauchen. Okay, also Ladegeräte
brauche ich auf jeden Fall nicht. Da habe ich genug. Ah, guck mal, eine Powerbank. Was haben
wir denn hier? 20.000 Milliamperestunden. Wie realistisch ist das, was die Hersteller da
draufschreiben? Welchen Mini-PC mit zwei Netzwerkbuchsen kannst du empfehlen? Hat
meiner zwei? Moment, ich muss mal kurz gucken. Hat meine nicht sogar zwei? Sekunde,
ich muss mal kurz gucken. Hey, der hat nur eine. Der hat nur eine. Aber warum willst du zwei
Netzwerksteckdosen haben? Vielleicht möchtest du dir nämlich irgendwelche Netzwerkgeräte bauen und
da gibt es meistens bessere Geräte für als die 0815 Mini-PCs. Als Firewall. Ja, siehste, da ist
so ein Mini-PC meistens gar keine so gute Idee. Also so ein Emulator-Mini-PC meistens gar keine so
gute Idee. Da gibt es viel bessere mit bis zu fünf Ports, habe ich gesehen. Wer ganz gute Reviews
macht auf YouTube dazu, ich kann dir keine empfehlen, aber ich kann dir sagen, was du dir
angucken kannst. Also im Zweifelsfall kannst du immer noch eine PC-X-Presskarte reinmachen. Der
hat ganz gute Tests für solche Netzwerk-Selbstbastel-Netzwerkdinger. Hier, guck, Blazingly
Fast Mini-PC. Der hat auch Mini-PCs getestet mit... Der Titel, alter, der Titel. Shocking,
Shocking, Shocking New 10 Gigabit Ethernet and 2.5 Gigabit Firewall. Shocking, Leute,
Shocking. Seid ihr auch so geschockt wie ich, wenn ihr das gesehen habt? Massively Shocking. Ja,
also das kannst du dir mal angucken, weil das sieht wirklich ganz... Also die Kiste hier sieht
tatsächlich ganz cool aus. Guck mal, da kriegst du ein Mini-PC mit 8 Ports oder 4 Ports und zweimal
SFP+. Das ist enorm Poggers. Und du musst mal gucken, der hat auch wirklich günstige Optionen.
Also schau dich mal auf dem Channel um, der hat viele solcher Sachen getestet. Und die... Also
ich verfolge die schon super lange hier, bevor die auf YouTube waren. Und das ist wirklich ein
Channel und auch ein Betreiber von der Seite. Den gönne ich den Erfolg hier auf YouTube auch. Das
ist auch ein bisschen Nische, das machen nicht so viele auf YouTube. Und die haben genau früher,
wie gesagt, die Webseite, da war ich schon total oft drauf und habe irgendwann die Reviews gelesen
von denen. Also der hat es auf jeden Fall verdient. Aber guck dir das mal an. Das lohnt sich. Da
findest du was. Seit wann spielt YouTube keine Videos mehr ab bei Adblock? Das haben manche. Ja,
manche Leute haben das. Das habe ich schon gesehen. Ich habe es noch nicht. Bei mir geht es noch. Aber
das habe ich schon gehört, ja. Apropos Adblock. Gibt es einen funktionellen Adblock für Twitch?
PrimeSub. Bester Adblock. Channel PrimeSub und dann hast du keine Werbung mehr. Ich muss aber
sagen, ich habe mich gerade etwas verlesen. Ich dachte, da steht Aporett. Ich habe das hier
gelesen und habe gedacht, was will er, Aporett? Ist der Insi-Modus wieder am Start? Nein,
aber Apropos Adblock. Gbay. Danke für den Sub. Und wie gesagt, schön, dass du den Weg
hergefunden hast von YouTube. Du bist ja nicht alleine, haben viele den Weg hergefunden. Aber
nur die Schlauen, weil die anderen checken nicht, dass ich hier Wubblers heiße. Was sind deine
Must-Have-Apps für einen Server? Es gibt eigentlich Apps. Apps kann man eh nicht so
wirklich dazu sagen. Es gibt ein Must-Have, was auf jedem Server installiert sein muss und das
ist SSH. Der Rest ist kontextspezifisch. Also je nachdem, was man machen will. Aber SSH muss
überall drauf. Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Hier, Powerbank. Wie schwer ist denn diese
Powerbank? Boah, nee, die ist zu fett. Die ist zu fett. Ein halbes Kilo mehr ins Fahrrad will
ich mir nicht packen. Da brauche ich irgendwas leichteres. Das ist mir zu fett. Ja, sowas hier.
Sowas hier schon eher. Es sind nicht 200k, es sind 20k. Und ob diese Angaben stimmen? Ich finde
gerade so die Storage Capacity Angaben, wie nennt man das auf Deutsch? Ladung, maximale Ladung oder
Ladung. Die ist immer sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen, was die Hersteller da angeben.
Zumindest das Ding ist eindeutig zu fett für mich. Ladekapazität, ja das ist das meine ich.
Noch mehr Charger. What? Ach, das ist so eine ergonomische Maus. Der Felix hatte früher mal
sowas. Da hat er voll geschwört drauf. Ich habe es nicht verstanden, wie man sowas verwenden kann.
Ein Adapter, USB-C, okay. Was sind das? Was bin ich denn hier gerade am sehen? Simple and
compact. Ja, sieht super ergonomisch aus, so mein Handy zu halten. Ach, das ist ein Magnet. Okay,
das ist eine Powerbank, die magnetisch laden kann. Also den Sinn verstehe ich nicht so wirklich.
Weil wenn ich irgendwo stationär bin, kann ich das USB-Kabel ans Handy anschließen. Und wenn ich
irgendwie unterwegs bin und es mobil verwenden will, dann ist eine normale Powerbank mit dem
USB-C Stecker doch viel angenehmer als die ganze Zeit so ein Ding hier dran zu klatschen, oder?
Darkside, danke für den Sub. Silver, danke für den Sub. POG Subscriptions, Leute. Exzellente.
Subscriber.
Ich muss nicht mehr Ladegeräte kaufen. Charger, wireless laden. Noch mal so ein komisches Ding.
Es wird ja immer mehr. Jetzt haben wir schon 24.000 mAh. Könnte man nicht einfach 24 Ah
schreiben? Das ist wie bei DSL. Bis zu 50.000 bis zu 200.000, das klingt einfach besser. Okay,
braucht man nicht. Braucht man alles nicht. Okay, ich skipp das mal, wenn jetzt bis hier
nichts dabei war. Aber tatsächlich. Achso, ja, ich bin ja hier nicht eingeloggt. Okay,
also tatsächlich den USB-Hub könnte ich echt noch gebrauchen. Das ist aber wirklich auch das
einzige. Grafikkarten brauche ich definitiv nicht. Preis auf absteigen. Ich will gucken,
was die teuerste ist. Bam. 40,90. MSI kaufe ich nicht. Seit mich MSI gebannt hat,
kaufe ich kein MSI mehr. Ist das, sind das, ja, das sind Noctua-Lüfter, ne? Sieht man sofort.
Das ist dieses, dieses Noctua-Kackbrauen. Aber eigentlich clever von Noctua. Die,
die haben auch so aus einer blöden Farbe so ein Markenzeichen gemacht. Ich meine,
das sieht schon echt hart Kacke aus, die Kombination hier von den Farben. Aber
wahrscheinlich kühlt es gut. Was bin ich, das ist, ach, das ist ein Case. Der Rest interessiert mich
nicht großartig. So, SSDs. Haben wir da irgendwas Spannendes dabei? Man kann doch hier oben noch
filtern, oder? Prime Day Deals. Guck mal, das war bestimmt nur Mist, was Amazon Freund hat.
So, jede Menge MicroSD-Karten. Da brauche ich keine, da habe ich genug. RAM. DDR4. Alter,
billig Zeug. Hör mal auf. Unter DDR5 mit RGB geht bei mir nix. Ist da eine SSD drin? Ach,
das ist dieses, für die, für die Xbox. Batterien. 40 Pack. Ey, das ist nicht schlecht. Das könnte
ich echt gebrauchen. Sind das, ja, ganz normale AAA-Batterien. Die könnte ich mir wirklich kaufen.
Batterien haben auch den Vorteil, die halten relativ lang. Haben quasi kaum Selbstentladung.
Die könnte ich ernsthaft brauchen. Ich habe nicht mehr so viele. Ist das Schrott? Echt,
wirklich? Warum ist das Schrott? Brauchst 40, warum nicht? Die halten eine Weile. Mir doch
egal, ob die aus der gleichen Fabrik kommen, sobald die, solange die funktionieren. SanDisk
Extreme. Da habe ich eine von. So extreme ist die gar nicht. Die wird heiß und die schafft auch
nicht lange schnelle Datenübertragung. War ich ein bisschen enttäuscht von, ehrlich gesagt.
Noch mal eine. Noch mal eine. Die wird extrem heiß, ja. 8 Seiten, nein, nein, nein. 8 Seiten
wird sich jetzt nicht angeguckt. SATA-SSDs sind komplett verschwunden, oder? Ach, hier ist ja noch
eine. Oder? Ist das eine? Nee. Portable. Das ist ein USB. Mini, wenn man nicht genug Platz hat.
Weil ich den Anwendungszweck auch so noch nicht gesehen habe. Das wundert mich bei den SanDisk-Dinger
nicht. Oh, tatsächlich noch eine SATA. Es gibt, es gibt sie noch, SATA-SSDs. Gut, nix, nix Spannendes
irgendwie dabei. Ja, das können wir auch weg machen. So, lasst uns mal kurz, ist bei Smart Home noch
irgendwas dabei, was, was interessant sein könnte? Das haben wir ja vorher nicht gesehen, weil Amazon
wieder nur komische. Sieht aus wie eine Wii, oder? Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Wii. Ist es nicht,
aber es sieht ein bisschen so aus. Xsens. Da ist WLAN, ist halt echt die Frage, wie lange hält da
die Batterie? Braucht alles keiner. Ah, hier haben wir Smart Locks. Braucht auch keiner. Außer manche im Chat.
SwitchBot Intelligent. Okay, was, was ist, was ist das? Hast du eine, was? Ach, eine Tasche mit Technik-Krams
drinnen. Du meinst so einen Notfall-Koffer oder sowas? Nö. Ich supporte, ich supporte keine Leute
mehr. Ach, das, jetzt check ich das. Das ist quasi ein für, für, für Jalousien. So ein Dreh, okay. Und,
und man kann es ohne Kabel betreiben, weil es ein, ein Solar, quasi eine Power Bank mit Solar dran
hat. Die Idee finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, weil für zwei, dreimal am Tag wird das nicht so viel
brauchen. Das Ding ist, die, ist das, ich brauche es nicht, weil ich habe keine Jalousien. Und ich
hoffe, man kann SwitchBot immer noch gescheit integrieren in Home Assistant. Ging ja vor
einer Weile noch ganz gut. Korrekt. Also, also 55 Euro für einen problichen Schalter ist schon
ganz schön, ganz schön teuer. Okay, ist auch nichts dabei. Es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich so
viel Schrott, man. Mini-PC, guck mal, hatten wir es doch gerade von. Da gibt es ein Minis-Forum. Was
ist denn ein Nub? Nub 6? Klingt ein bisschen nach Noob. Hat fast, hat fast den gleichen Formfaktor
wie die alten Nooks. Ist doch bestimmt Absicht, oder? Guck mal, der hat sogar zwei, zwei Stöpsel.
Ein Luna-Controller. Was ist ein Luna-Controller? Eine ganze Gaming-Welt in deiner Hand. Für
Amazon-Spiele? Amazon, öh, öh, öh. Ich dachte jetzt, als ich gesehen habe, die ganze, ich dachte,
das ist so ein Meta-Controller, der auf Xbox, PC und so alles mit, mit einfach mit, mit sich koppeln
lässt und dann per Tastendruck umschalten oder so. Aber ne, in der, für Amazon-Spiele-Service,
hör mal doch auf. Was kommt als nächstes? Stadia wieder, oder wie? Wie sieht es eigentlich so aus
mit Stadia? Stadia-Service is no longer available? Stimmt, ich vergaß, ich vergaß. Ich habe es
vergessen, Leute. Ich habe es, ich habe es verdrängt. Es ist ja schon längst Geschichte. Könnt ihr euch
noch daran erinnern, wie die alle es angetan haben, als bricht ein neues Gaming-Zeitalter an? Und ich
habe mir damals schon gedacht, Alter Leute, jetzt steigert euch doch nicht so rein. Keck. Ja,
da war es bestimmt. Das, da muss es, muss es dran gelegen haben. So, ne, das ist uninteressant hier.
Terra Master, hochleistungsnass. Mit, also, so Hochleistung kann das mit die, mit dem, mit den
Boards nicht sein. Die sind, ich meine, die sind nicht, nicht irgendwie super mies für, aber
Hochleistung ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben mit dem, mit der Hardware drin. Es reicht fast
alles für nass, wenn du es nur als nass verwenden willst, außer alte Raspberry Pis. Aber dann
sollte man nicht Hochleistung dranschreiben. Was ist das? What? Ach, USB OTG, das ist ein USB
Antriebs ist im Prinzip einfach nur ein USB Stick. Warum das hier so komische weiße Fläche drauf hat,
checke ich auch nicht genau. Ach, Fingerabdruck. Okay, ja, wer braucht, der braucht. Schöne viele
bunte, billige USB Sticks, die mega langsam sind und wahrscheinlich instant kaputt gehen. Typische,
typische Werbegeschenke packen. USB Sticks. Alter, Lake. USB Dogging Station. Das ist
eigentlich mega Six Head. Ich habe mir auch mal sowas gekauft, das hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das ist mit der Zeit immer weiter runtergegangen und einmal habe ich mir den Arm dran angehauen,
beim Aufstehen. Seitdem habe ich es nie verwendet. Man kann, man kann auch einfach sein Smartphone
oder Tablet sich so auf den Bauch stellen oder in der Hand halten oder aufs Kissen legen. Outdoor
Access Point. Ja, ziemlich viel Kacke, oder? Beim Prime Day wieder. So viel random zusammengeworfenes
Zeug einfach nur. Netzwerkkabel kann man immer brauchen, aber irgendwann ist auch mal gut. Ich
habe mehr als genug Netzwerkkabel, USBs und HDMI Kabel. Ich habe hier letztens mal bei mir alles
ein bisschen aufgeräumt und sortiert. Ich habe eine ganze Kiste voller USB Kabel, eine ganze
Kiste voller Netzwerkkabel und eine ganze Kiste voller HDMI Kabel und sowas. Komplett unsinnig.
Da muss ich mir wahrscheinlich zu Lebzeiten nichts mehr kaufen von. Das ist ein typischer
China-Chinesen-Name irgendwie. Könnte auch was anderes sein, aber vom Namen her würde ich sagen,
klingt übelst nach einem China-Shop. Lass uns doch mal gucken. Mal gucken, ob mein China-Detektor
richtig funktioniert. Oh ne, doch nicht. Ich glaube, mein China-Detektor hat gefailt. Moment,
wo sehen wir denn, von wo die herkommen? Wobei der Shop sieht ziemlich China-Chinesen-0815 aus.
Brand-Story, Terms of Use, Contact Us. Ja, mein China-Detektor hat funktioniert, Leute. China-Detektor
wusste ich es doch. Love Fuck steht da. Love Fuck. Das ist so ein Ding, was die Chinesen
sich random generieren. So ein typischer China-Produkt oder markenname. Nochmal China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Load your world. Okay, Ambor. Was? Die Webseite hört sich schon China-Chinesen-mäßig an. What the
fuck? Wo bin ich hier gelandet? The fuck? Bangladesch? Okay, was auch immer. Genau so
erfinden die die Dinger. Wobei ich glaube, die machen sich nicht mal die Mühe,
eben über Chat-GPT zu fragen, sondern die haben einfach irgendeinen random Generator aus dem
englischen Wörterbuch. Die klingen alle... und die sind doch alle immer groß... das auch wieder.
Die sind doch alle prinzipiell immer groß geschrieben. Hans Sunny ist garantiert auch
China-Chinesen-Zeug. Benfai. Okay, die machen vom Namen her schon mal gar keinen Held raus.
Wenn das nicht China-Chinesen-Zeug ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Benfai. Jetech. Das ist alles
China-Chinesen-Zeug. Hypergun. Ja gut, von Anker wissen wir es, dass es China-Chinesen-Zeug ist.
Das ist aber noch eines der bekanntesten China-Chinesen-Produkte, Anker. Das kann ich
nicht mal aussprechen. Rav... was? Ravidb. Ravidb. Das kann man... das ist nicht aussprechbar.
Ravi... ah ne, Raviat. Das... da steht aber nicht A. Da steht Ravidb. Ja, mir ist auch klar,
dass es ein A sein soll. Ah, nix dabei. So, hier. Professional, Leute. Was gibt es? Die G502 ist
im Prime-Deal. Okay, G502 ist eine nice Maus, auch wenn ich sie nicht mal verwende. Wenn man ein
bisschen, kein Problem, ein bisschen minimal schwerere Maus mag, dann ist die G502 gut. Wenn
man sie noch schwerer haben will, noch besser, weil die hat Gewichte dabei. So, der ist nice.
Den habe ich auch am Start. Wobei, nicht exakt den, das ist das Vorgangermodell, aber der ändert
sich ja immer nicht so viel dazwischen. Der ist wirklich nice und mit dem habe ich bisher fast
alles daheim geschraubt und gebohrt bekommen. Ist das der mit Bohr... Bohrstelzen? Nein,
ist es nicht. Aber man kann damit trotzdem bohren. War nicht ganz so effektiv, aber man kann damit
trotzdem bohren. Muss man ein bisschen dagegen drücken. Akkublaser brauche ich nicht. Teppichmesser
habe ich schon, brauche ich nicht. Haben die das jetzt umbenannt? Früher war immer... früher war
immer GSR und GBR oder sowas mit Schlagfunktionen und ohne. Bosch Professional Laserentfernungsmesser.
Ein Tacker? Ja okay, brauche ich nichts von. Ich bevorzuge für PC-Zusammenschrauben manuelle
Schraubendreher und kein Elektro-Kram. Bier, Wein und Spirituosen? Die wollen uns das aber auch jetzt
echt unterschieben, oder? Schon wieder. Also so unglaublich viel Schrott. Comfy Haushaltsgeräte.
Mikrowelle. Wenn Toshiba macht Mikrowellen. Ich kann mich nur noch an Festplatten von... Moment,
bringe ich das durcheinander? Chat, haben die früher Festplatten gemacht oder bringe ich das
gerade durcheinander? Nee, das war Hitachi, glaube ich. Das bringe ich durcheinander.
Oder haben die auch Festplatten gemacht? Laptops. Laptops haben sie gemacht. Dann sind die ein
bisschen wie Samsung. Samsung macht auch alles. Von der SSD bis zum Bagger. Frage ist, ob die
Bagger mit SSDs haben. Ja Mitsubishi macht auch... meine Klimaanlage ist von Mitsubishi. Aber
Samsung ist koreanisch und Toshiba ist dann wahrscheinlich japanisch. Also von Yama kenne
ich hauptsächlich Audio-Zeug. Brauche keinen Wäschetrockner. Ich habe schon einen Wäschetrockner.
Kühlschrank auch nicht. Ja, Motorrad interessiert mich nicht. Ich bringe die hauptsächlich mit
Audio-Equipment irgendwie in Verbindung. Comfy Dunstabzugshaube. Ja, sowas hätte ich mal
gebraucht, als mein Opa noch gelebt hat. Mein Opa hatte nämlich, wahrscheinlich kommt es noch aus
dem Krieg oder so, die Angewohnheit, auch im Winter, wenn es kalt war, die Heizung nicht anzumachen.
Weil ist doch warm genug. Gut, er war im Krieg in Russland. Da war es deutlich kälter und er hat es
trotzdem überlebt. Aber trotzdem, man kann im Winter durchaus mal 18 Grad plus im Wohnzimmer haben,
wenn man da den ganzen Tag drin sitzt. Aber wollte er nicht. Und ich hätte ihm damals einfach in den
Radiator reinstellen sollen. So, das steht jetzt da. Das machen wir jetzt einfach an. Auch ein
bisschen, muss man sagen, da kommt eins zum anderen. Also mein Opa war immer super knauserig,
was das Heizen angeht. Er wollte nie heizen. Er hat immer gesagt, es ist immer warm genug und das
braucht man nicht. Immer Tür zu, keine zwei Sekunden Tür auf. Also super sparsam, aber halt
schon, sagen wir mal so, schon gesundheitsschädlich sparsam, wenn es dann teilweise 16, 17 Grad da
gewesen ist. Und er ist gestorben an den Folgen, das kann man so nicht direkt sagen, aber ich
vermute mal an den Folgen von der Lungenentzündung, die wahrscheinlich eventuell mit ausgelöst wurde,
dadurch, dass es immer so kalt war im Wohnzimmer. Also der Doktor meinte die Lungenentzündung,
weil er irgendwie zu hastig, pass mal auf, man kann sterben durch zu hastig essen. Der Doktor
hat gemeint, Lungenentzündung ausgelöst höchstwahrscheinlich irgendwie durch Speisereste
in der Lunge. Es kommt, wenn man zu sehr schnauft und isst und so alles gleichzeitig macht und das
über einen langen Zeitraum. Der hat ja auch das Essen immer übelst reingeschlungen, ja,
das kam ja auch noch vom Krieg. Und dann auch kalt im Wohnzimmer, dann Lungenentzündung. Mit
Lungenentzündung ist er ins Krankenhaus gekommen und eigentlich war die Lungenentzündung schon
wieder fast vorbei oder war eigentlich schon wieder gut, hat er überlebt. Da haben sie ihn
auf eine so ja Rentner-Rentner-Station gepackt zum Erholen und auf einmal rufen die an und meinte,
der hat nachts Herzstillstand. Sie hatten ihn dann noch reanimiert, aber da war halt,
ja, war nix mehr zu machen. Der lag da halt dann keine Ahnung, paar Minuten quasi schon tot rum,
da haben sie ihn noch reanimiert und zwei Tage später oder so ist er dann endgültig gestorben.
Und ich denke mir so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich war er nicht, also ich weiß nicht, ob das was
damit zu tun hatte, aber ich finde, in gewissem Zusammenhang lässt sich da schon gut ableiten von
gerade Lungenentzündung und immer im Kalten gehockt noch zusätzlich. Ist durchaus möglich,
ja, dass das mit dadurch ausgelöst wurde. Auf der anderen Seite, ja, das kommt dazu,
im Alter wird man auch noch empfindlicher. Auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube, ich könnte mir
auch im Alter nix besseres vorstellen, nicht die Lungenentzündung, nicht die Lungenentzündung,
aber quasi Herzstillstand im Schlaf, nachts im Krankenhaus so, also einen besseren Ort den
Löffel abzugeben gibt es doch eigentlich nicht. Also einen besseren Ort und einen besseren,
und wo du nix von mitkriegst. Du kriegst nix von mit und du liegst gleich im Krankenhaus,
wo sie dich direkt entsorgen können oder preparen für das. Also insofern das,
also wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte, würde ich es auch so machen. Oder verbrennen halt,
verbrennen halt. Entsorgen war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen das falsch gewählte Wort, ja,
verbrennen. Also wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte für meine Angehörigen, die ich nicht habe,
weil ich keine Kinder habe und auch nicht vorab ein Kind dazu habe, man weiß ja nie,
ja, dann würde ich mir das auch so aussuchen. Ja, warum nicht? So, gibt's noch irgendwas Chat?
Habt ihr irgendwelche super geheimen mega Empfehlungen für den Prime Day? Habt ihr
irgendwas gekauft? Irgendwas, was ich noch gucken muss? Ach, die Viewer, ja. Gucken,
ob ich mit, keine Ahnung, 87 noch 213 Viewer hab. Ob ich überhaupt so alt werde? Ich mein,
immerhin, ich mach jetzt ordentlich Sport. Hat zwar gedauert bis fast 40, aber immerhin.
Fire-TV? Nee, brauch ich nicht, will ich. Water-Batterien, sind die im Angebot? Also
wie gesagt, Packen-Batterien brauche ich tatsächlich. Oh, schlugen auf. An die
Lidungsadmins hier im Chat, wie viel hat man im Beruf tatsächlich mit Modprobe und ähnlichen
Befehlen zu tun? Selten. Weißt du, für was ich am häufigsten Modprobe brauche? Um bei
nervigen Kisten den PC-Speaker zu unloaden, dass sie nicht piepsen. Modprobe minus RPC-Speaker.
Das ist, glaube ich, mein meistbenutzter Modprobe-Befehl. Ansonsten Modprobe und sowas
sehr selten. Was man öfters mal braucht, ist sowas wie LS-USB, LS-PCI, minus T,
BLK-ID und LS-BLK und solche Sachen. Das braucht man öfters, wenn es um Hardware-Peripherie geht,
aber Modprobe ist wirklich selten. Der LPIC ist halt ein Zertifikat, Zertifikate sind meistens
schwachsinnig. Wobei ich glaube, der LPIC ist noch eines der etwas minimal weniger
schwachsinnigen Zertifikate. Ja, eine Packung Batterien könnte ich mir tatsächlich mal
bestellen. Sind 40 Stück, ich brauche, also 40 ist halt schon ordentlich und davon könnte ich
auch noch eine Packung brauchen. Also sind das die gleichen? Sind das die gleichen und die kosten
einfach mal irgendwie 8 mehr als? Ne, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das sind Akkus und das sind
Batterien. Ach so, ja. Und dann sind die auch, ah ne, die sind auch in AA-Form. Das hat ernsthaft
Batterien drin, das Ding? Ne, ich nicht. Okay, dann gibt es anscheinend wirklich nichts, was man
unbedingt braucht. Samsung-SSD, 4TB. Das ist doch aber bestimmt eine SATA-SSD, oder? Wahrscheinlich
eine CUVO oder sowas. Ne, eine EVO. Ja, wer braucht, der braucht. SSDs kann man ja prinzipiell nur durch
noch mehr SSDs erstellen. Ja, leider ist bei sehr vielen nicht mehr TASMOTA möglich, das ist ziemlich
kacke. Ich glaube, die TASMOTA-Zeiten sind auch ein bisschen vorbei. Zumindest für Umflashen, ja, für
eigene Sachen sind die immer noch wunderbar. Wird es auch in Zukunft weiterhin bleiben und wahrscheinlich
eines der besten Plattformen. Gut, Chat, erstellen, äh, ich meine, ersetzen. Es ist spät, ich muss jetzt
schlafen. Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. See you.